那接下来又进入我们今天活动的第二个环节一维一访谈首先是第一个问题我们可能会每个嘉宾我们都会问每个讲述我们都会问就是目前比如像泽磊在团队里面是成了一个什么样的角色呢目前是我已经开门了我目前是那个摆脱小说团队的扣端的一个负责人OK泽磊是不是碰到什么情况了请你处理一下不好意思不好意思
刚刚说到我目前就是把多小说的一个扣端团队负责人目前主要是目前主要工作一方面是技术上的话我们也还在做然后技术上首先我其实目前整个团队也会有一些其他的技术问题嘛因为我们整个代码是从19年从别的团队接过来的所以说整个代码对我们而言历史负赛也比较重这两年一直都是逢逢步步所以说整个技术上的挑战我们也是一直存在再者说
从管理方面来讲说跟之前不同的一点是说我们猜目前来讲我们前参与业务的成就会高一些同时也会关注不同的团队成员的一个成网诉求其实也是为了让团队更活力一些嗯OK对我想了解一下就是你刚讲的就是我们这个历史负载比较重的嘛就你们过程中有做过什么大的成构吗
我们近期是在做一些重过的工作包括把整个家伙去做一些改善因为以前那套架构来讲就是大家常用大家最受的懂的一个点就是说所有的文化都合在一起嗯对这个是所有业务的业务开发的同学都会碰到的问题业务团队对
然后像你们现在的业务程度比较高的话我理解其实你们核心的整个引擎应该之前已经都比较完备了对不对比较稳定了排版部分是因为去年开始做完之后基本上是很稳定的那你们现在等于是在业务这边层能度比较高就是可能是会结合我们的我要整个阅读区别核心然后会做一些周边的一些其他的类似一些其他的业务是吧
对对对然后呢其实就是你我之前来讲还是说没有代替的就是自己也是一个独立开发嘛那么之前来讲其实是不太去关注像业务的一些收益啊等等但是当你去负责一个团队的时候其实会也会关注一些像业务的实际的收益也等等因为业务做不好其实大家都不好对吧对这个这个我很理解就是我们这样说业务团队如果有业务做是好
如果你一直发现你没有业务做那你这个团队就很危险了但是我其实也体谅也非常体谅其他的团队同学嘛就是因为我也是从这边过来的嘛因为我在作为普通人开发的时候我其实是不太也不是自身也不是很关注业务我在开发的过程中其实我平时是更关注一些比如我可以参加哪些参与哪些有提出深度的项目等等我其实更关注进入方面
所以說我也明白像團隊的其他成員肯定也是跟關注資深的技術成長所以說我也會平時會盡量的去看一看大家一些技術訴求等等我們看看有什麼項目是可以結合到我們業務開發中去做一些技術項目這樣的事情我理解剛剛還有個看了直播鏡的朋友問到說如果提升團隊的技術氛圍像你剛剛講的那個點其實就是一個提升團隊技術氛圍很好的一個方式就是從
听你的的角度来说去考虑到大家比如说一些技术的成长的诉求这个其实是一个出发点对那刚刚你刚讲了这个点我就想问一下第二个问题就是因为你刚讲到一个不同阶段的问题你也是从不同开发点过来了那其实我想了解一下就从新手开发点到现在你经历过哪些成长阶段呢我觉得可以从更早一点比如说从你上学的时候开了讲可能会我觉得上学的话我应该是从
很早就开始做我上去我大三开始做Fs开发的当时其实lc比较早期可能那会才lc三lc四吧可能才lc四我记得现在比较早期对对对然后整个我觉得一个呈场过程我觉得是一个对技术不断重新认知的一个过程因为一开始来讲大家都是为了满足功能需求其实说白了都是在画画UI这些对吧嗯基本了画画UI我满足大多数的业务需求了
这是第一个阶段第二个阶段来讲其实是会说除了满足业务功能需求之外你可能会去考虑开始优化一些代码等等那么这时候你可能会去关注一些像别人三方控制怎么实现的为什么这么涉及包括系统的API为什么这么涉及等等你会参考一些很多设计模式也好包括对家库的理解也好这一块来讲这时候你新系统的代码可能会更加的好一些更一维护更让别人看懂这是第二个阶段我觉得
第三个就让来讲我是觉得是开始独立负责某一部模块例如像我刚才前面讲的我可能独立开发一下阅读器的这个模块这样的话因为整个模块确实是比较多你就需要考虑别人使用的时候你的API应该怎么设计然后整个模块内部你需要考虑方方面面的设计那么其实我们也知道软件加过里面再复杂的模块我们也可以进行逐步的拆解对吧但是当你模块多的时候那么它其实就是形成一定的复杂度
那么也就是说第三个阶段来讲就是说我认为是负责一些有难度的一些大的一个文化这是我觉得第三个阶段吧第四个阶段来讲我是觉得是说可以负责一个整个一个项目比如说你去负责具体的某一个业务项目
是百度小说也好或者百度阅读也好那么你负责一个项目的时候那么必然这个项目里面其实有更多的团队成员一块是参与那么这里面就不单纯的是说你的技术选项你的价格设计等等的问题你还涉及到团队的协同等等的问题这是我觉得是另一个阶段那么再往后一个阶段的时候你可能会负责多个项目因为一个右团队也可能会有多个项目像我们就有百度小说我们也有对外的输出Stk等等那么在多个项目的时候你怎么去看
一些技術選項因為你的一個技術選項可以在多個項目共用也好或者是說每個項目的資深特點你可以根據資深不同的項目特點去選項對應的一個技術也好那麼這時候你要考慮的事情會更多一些我覺得是這樣的幾個過程我明白其實我理解了這個東西其實可能處理的問題的複雜度會越來越高對吧然後在各個階段可能對於你的要求其實也不太一樣
是包括思考的问题的方式也会有一些变化对嗯 我明白所以其实我理解可能在那个比如说开始独立负责一个项目的时候是不是就是整个思路让我开始会开始发生一些比较大的转变对对对因为你考虑的不是说只能把这块代码写好就可以了对对因为你讲到比如说可能在独立负责某个模块呢应该还是自己一个人在做对不对但是一到到了独立负责一个项目的时候可能就不是自己一个人了
对对对因为这里面涉及到跟团队合作啊协同啊等等嗯对我也觉得在这个过程中其实变化比较大对你可能你的整个思路就变成了比如说你再负责某某快的时候可能就会就是你的思路就是你自己是最强的是对吧但是你一旦开始负责项目的时候就好像就你不一定要是就就就不一定是说是每个方面都是最强的对吧
对对因为也是同行相亲网自己写一份文化的时候就觉得自己写的代码是好的然后看大家就觉得哇这什么呀哈哈哈哈我可能过段时间发现我卡在代码是自己写的哈哈哈我明白对那其实刚好就讲到因为刚讲就是这个歌卷有不同的特性嘛但是我觉得可能有一些点啊就是在这个过程中我觉得应该还是有一些点是不变的
就可能对于你整个成长的过程中肯定还是有一些点是对你来说你觉得蛮重要的那其实就想问一下就说你觉得你成长帮助比如说如果要选最大的三个点你会选什么呢这个问题我其实想了一下如果我是可能刚工作一两年我可能还真的能找到三个点但我现在感觉你想找个出具体的三个点了对我是觉得每次工作中的挑战其实它都会让你成长那么这个成长也可能是纪录上也可能是项目管理上
不久的意思比如说当这个项目比较难或者说他会用到一些你之前没有接触到的一些技术领域的时候那么起码在技术深度或者是技术广播上你可能会有一个收获再者说说如果项目比较大的时候那么他参与的人比较多比较那么在项目管理上你可能也会有一个收获然后其实我还有关键就是说因为正常来讲我们在平时在
做开发的时候我们可能一年来讲大家都在按部就班的去做我们的正常的工作迭代业务迭代也好实际上我想说的是正常来讲不会总会遇到挑战的然后我也想表达一个观点就是说当你遇到一些挑战的时候你也不要管它压力大还是怎么样也好我觉得大家可以是努力去抓住的把它做好因为这样才会体现出你和别人的不同对吧嗯 我明白
对 我觉得经过你讲这个点其实我是倒觉得还是有一些有一些共性的点比如说你讲到挑战这个点就是其实就是说可能对于对你感觉就是比如说我们在整个过程其实不断的一届挑战那其实我是觉得你在面对这个挑战过程中还是很积极的对吧因为我觉得不会总遇到挑战平时的工作大多数都很平平的嘛
很频频那比如说你觉得你在碰到这个挑战过程的时候你是怎么样去处理就是你看到你就说你要去努力去抓住嘛所以我是觉得至少你在面对这个挑战的时候你的整个态度还是很积极的对但是其实也不是说你每件挑战都能做的成功啊也会遇到一些工作上一些失败啊或者是一些可能因为打击也好但是我觉得是说无论是失败也好还是打击也好或者怎么样我觉得只要你没有因此去真正去躺穿的话那么
你也會去成長了 畢竟11線還長一字 對吧明白 明白 難道我理解了 對所以其實我覺得還是有些共性的就整個至少在比如說面對這些問題的一個狀態上面其實我覺得哲磊還是非常非常積極的這個跟我們之前的其實講師我們聊的講師其實也差不多大家普遍就是在面對一些挫折或者說挑戰的時候都是會用比較積極心態去面對這個其實還蠻重要的因為
我们可能又聊到今年比如像今年这个整个大的行情不好嘛大家可能有很多同学也会面对一些挫折但是我觉得大家在面对这个挫折过程中还是说要想办法去怎么样去正面迎接这个挑战然后怎么样去克服这个挑战可能会更重要一些是的好的然后那我们再讲一个可能跟今天主题比较贴切的一个话题吧
对 因为看今天则得讲这个话题还是相对比较深的嘛讲了这个排版 甚至讲到私下家所以我想了解一下就是比如说你是如何去系统化的去进行一个底层技术的一个学习呢因为这个还比较难其实我觉得那个像体层学习的话我觉得最好的方式还是说你真正讲说你工作场景会遇到某些一些底层技术方向的时候你再去学习因为我觉得如果像体层技术的话你仅仅凭兴趣去自己学的话如果一直没有沿用场景也很容易忘记
不过我觉得许多的底层技术影像音质品也好包括我刚刚讲的排版等等它其实都是平台无关的那么其实我觉得大家可以多去了解一下CCI因为这些很多技术都需要一定的CCI基础这是我当你当你遇到了这种底层需要一些底层技术的工作的时候你如果掌握这些像你掌握一些CCI-2之类的话你可能会很好的去上手这个事情然后再者是说我讲排版的话我也我做排版的话实际上是由
引入的人 因为我在之前的部门来讲的话 谁是有一个排版专家这样的一个人其实一直在带我的 我其实也非常感谢 因为如果光让我自己去看的话 排版人有很多东西 排版规则 排版技巧包括编码 自布编码等等我其实是找不到方向的 对其实我也是有人这样带着去学的 对所以其实我也很感谢啊OK 所以其实我总结下来 第一个就是首先要有方向 对吧这个方向很重要 然后第二个就是需要有一个使用场景
就还是要实践出真知嘛你不能就是如果只是说去学学然后你也不实践的话可能很多坑你也不踩不到然后你可能也用不到然后另外还第三个点就是说这个私压家的基础要去打牢我不知道是不是理解核心的还是这三个点对对对然后如果是真的是想说工作场景用到的话但你又对某一东西很感兴趣的话那么我觉得你学习功能松应该也不要只看书或者只看文章
然后尝试去自己写一个给自己做一个项目的设计自己去按照项目设计去完成一个项目那么你可能才会真正去了解这样的一个某个方向的技术OK是要公实这样的这个明白好的然后我再跟直播间同学再强调一下就三个核心点第一个方向要找准第二个一定要就是要在时间中去学习那第三个就是私压加这个东西底子还是要打好的好吧如果说直播间有一些
就是比如说在校园里面的同学或者说比较初级的同学也想往这个底层上面去做探索的话这三个点很重要好吧OK那第五个问题就是关于这个职业生涯这个问题因为我看其实我们在直播间刚才有同学也在问说这个比如说一些大专的毕业的就是他现在怎么去进大厂大家肯定会有很多这样的职业生涯的困惑嘛就想了解一下比如说你在这个困惑中是怎么去处理的
其实职业生涯里面我所有的困惑基本上都不太在技术上因为我觉得技术特别好的一点就是说哪怕你这个技术不了解也好或者哪怕它比较深也好但是你花一段时间去付出的话那么你总会去大概了解至少大概会了解这个技术对所以说基本上大多数的困惑都不在技术上而且我更多的困惑基本都在职业生涯上例如说我到了这个时间点我应该去怎么选择是做一些
偏向于项目管理的工作也好还是更往往一个技术去钻研还要说但我觉得这个技术我想去再去看看是否去做一些跨平台的技术等等我觉得这是关于职业生涯上的一些选择上的问题对这块其实是有时候你会常常会遇到困扰基本上我觉得每年我都会有这样的各种的问题但是case太多了对我明白所以其实就是
那对于我想问一下就比如像你在做选择的过程中你是怎么样去就是做一个基本的判断的呢就是你比如说可能你你脑中会有一个流程啊就这个流程大概怎么去走一下去做这样的一个选择呃基本上你要做一个选择的话其实是关系到可能你未来半年至少半年半年到一年的一个呃工作都可能都跟着意思相关所以说我还是想我会往后面想讲说未来一年两年之后我这个选择是否是正确的
那麼我是否是應該這麼選擇主要還是會往長遠去看一看而不是說我例如說可能最近流行什麼東西然後我可能就去做我可能但是我基本上不太會去這麼去選擇這個問題而是說看我真正說一是我興趣點到底是在什麼第二個是說我真正想要的是什麼對我會思考這兩個問題然後再去做一些基礎同的選擇或者職業上的選擇這種這個點
确实也挺有益举同工之妙的就是首先第一个肯定要知道自己想要的东西这个很重要对吧然后可能做规划的时候第二个点就是我们要看的长远一点就不能被眼前的一些利益或者说热度的东西所去吸引嘛对 举个简单例子影像面对很多东西可能会考虑像跳槽长期要还工作这种其实很多大家都会考虑这个问题但是我其实考虑的像跳槽或者长期这样的问题来讲其实只要是你目前我是个人觉得
如果除非地方给的钱真的是太多了对吧这个不说吧正常来讲的话你要考虑跳槽的话其实像我我个人也会考虑一个跳槽成本的问题额外成本就是说我要去一个新的环境我要去构建额外的一个信任关系也好等等这些其实是我假如说面对工作选择中我也会考虑的一个问题就不单单会考虑说钱呀具体工作做的什么内容啊这种会单单去考虑这个问题明白
明白好的那反正我觉得其实就是两个比较核心的点嘛第一个想要加在想做什么然后把眼光放长远至少完两年以后去看然后去帮助其做这样一个选择好的OK那其实说到选择问题啊其实就是另外一个问题就是现在你是已经是作为负责人了嘛对吧团队的负责人那你是怎么去决定这个团队的一个技术体系的眼睛呢嗯
就是体系的话我主要看两点第一个就是收益以及第二点是说适合我觉得首先技术选项也好包括架构设计也好其实我们仔细想想他们往往都是不影响这套系统是否可以运行对吧他们所以其实整个无论是架构也好技术演技也好等等重构也好其实一直来讲它是一个重要不紧急的事对吧所以说我假如说让我去做技术演技
核心考虑的还是说它真正能够带给我们什么样的一个收益因为像我也是生存业务的嘛例如你现在PMT一个需求它可能会标识说我这个需求产生什么样的收益以及这个收益逻辑是怎么样预估的但是我发现其实我们很多时候做技术的时候我们做一个纪录需求的时候可能写的收益就可能是写的降低偶和对不对
这种加购更清晰降低有盒这可能是我们写的项目收益但其实这在我看来不是项目收益这其实是一个技术者表象对吧我是认为我是说像技术演技也好加过设计也好我们真正还是要关心体校这个目标的因为我们也想说我们也想说加过设计的核心宗旨到底是什么
我覺得架構設計的核心種子就是要用最小的人力成本去維護和構建這套軟件所以說我們做任何架構包括做任何技術的選項等等我們要考慮的一定是提效的這個問題這是我們關於軟件架構上面上最核心需要考慮的東西然後再者是說我前面提到說適合就是說有些架構可能會適合別的團隊
但是我们其实在技术选选的时候我们也需要根据自己团队的一个技术层面的一个技术战啊包括团队的技术积累去考虑比如说有些技术在别的团队很成功例如一些跨平台方案可能在别的团队很成功其实我们引进来的话对我们团队可能不一定好吃所以说这也是我关注的一个点明白但我觉得刚讲这两点点其实我可以看出来那个则得确实应该
看架构的书看到不少合适这个东西其实我觉得架构里面非常核心的一个点就是甭管你是做什么什么模式什么之类的这个合适其实是最重要的然后讲到第二个那个点我刚第二点讲的是什么来着就是对关于收益的问题你刚讲那点确实很有意思因为我其实在做管理嘛我经常看大家写那个大写技校甭管写KPI还写OK啊只要是架构优化的项目
往往大家都写不清楚我这个东西的成果到底是什么对我我经常每次看到这样的家伙都会说你为什么写还写的还是一个过程指标对吧就你刚讲那个所谓的降低偶和还是个过程指标吗他他并不是一个结果指标我们结果指标肯定往往是要需要一些数据来说话的对所以你刚才对影响公司都是
资本能嘛对吧资本允许你去花很多时间去做架构一定不是为了满足你程序员的所谓的变成理想呀对不对是的是的对一定是说要就是要么就是要么就是降本要么就提效嘛这个是公司最最关心的东西要么就是一夜不做的就能挣钱对所以所以我觉得刚才泽雷讲那个点很好就是你一定要想想提效的这些东西所以如果说大家直播间同学就后面还要再写这种比如说你要做的一个架构优化项目你要先想想你的
成果到底怎么写而且写的话可以像则得讲这个角度就是你怎么样去提效比如说你能提效百分之多少啊比如说这个东西原来我只需要两个人答案我只需要一个人做啊这个其实就是一个比较核心的指标了ok那我们现在看一下后面的问题吧这可能是大家比较关心的就是首先问个题外话我们现在团队还在招人吗目前是在招人目前在招人哦你们还在招人你看没有直播间就注意一下他们还在招人
真正有对我们感兴趣的可以投简历给我直接微信发我就可以OK赶快进群啊赶快通过右下角的那个二维码进去我们现在这里有还在抗的那这又比较是要比较重要的问题就是可以先给直播间同学讲一讲就是我们比较看中这个候选人什么样的品质呢
或者人品的话其实各个团队要求也不一样然后我的话的话在技术上的话我会看重例如 iOS 开发工程师我看重两个方面一方面是 iOS另一方面是工程师这两个维度首先 iOS 的话那么至少是在你所技术的
对应的领域,无论是iOS也好,Android也好,你得有在你的技术方向上有一定的技术基础以及技术深度,另一方面就是共同诗这个温度,那么它涉及到可能是基础基因原理,算法,数据结构这些,那么它其实是所有程序,我觉得都应该必备的一个考量,所以说我整个来讲就会从两方面考虑就像你前面提到的,一个是你的技术方向上。
我們會考慮一個深度也好廣度也好對另一個就是說你的作為程序員那個基礎就是工商師這個維度然後這是一個技術方面的一個考量然後軟實力上我們其實主要關注的還是一個溝通伺服順暢這些因為我是覺得把一件事情說清楚其實是一個很重要的能力然後我覺得這裡面其實有關係到你的邏輯能力那麼通過假如說我們面試的話半小時到一小時之間那麼其實是
那么我们沟通是否顺畅其实也是一个重要的考核的一个方向其实主要是两方面嗯 ok所以这里我讲一个点就是关于讲到这个逻辑的能力我可以给大家一个比较小的tips就是如果大家需要讲一个东西的话可以建议大家采用1234这样的方式去表达就是这个时候会让你的逻辑能力提高很多对这个是
我这边给大家一个小tips吧如果你面试的时候比如说你要去别人会问你做了一个什么项目那你肯定最好的方式就是第一 第二 第三用这种方式去讲的话你的整个内容会非常非常的清晰这个是一个题外话就是如果大家要去面试的话这里可以讲一讲关于软实力方面技术方面就没得说了技术方面刚才泽雷讲到了这个东西就是看你的深度还包括你的技术能力对吧
这种东西就是说没有什么小的tips 反正就只能认识真正的去扎拉斯斯的血了OK那你现在招的这个觉得是什么样的一个要求啊你从那边吗就你们现在招的这个人大概是什么样的一个要求我们从t4到t6应该都有在招吧啊 那这个范围范围还很广很广 那刚好我就问一下下面一个问题啊对 刚好接上了 对
就是你们现在各个级别都在找码那你们比如说各个级别的成员在技术上面测重的点是什么就这个我觉得其实就是像我前面讲的一个成长路径其实是各个级别其实是可以按照我前面讲的一个成长路径去看的我觉得第一个像可能是说第一个阶段可能是说不断巩固领域内的技术能力对吧满足岗位的日常开发这个其实我们正常来讲可能提四就够了对吧
第二階段来讲是其实是希望可以负责一个独立的文化参与一些包括自己参与包括设计一个topic这个其实我们是呃像会要求呃背面是这个假如说到了t5这个程度我们会要求可能他希望可以达到一个独党一面的这样一个能力至少可以完成自己去calibrate某一个化我觉得这样的话至少t5要达到这种程度对如果再往上的话我觉得是那你负责一个项目
业务上技术法门技术上你可以方方面面的去开网这里面其实也关系到像积极性包括责任性这些东西我们也比较看重那么这个时候也就是说在我上期的同学可能会关注一下这些方面的东西就不单单只能会关注一些技术方面的东西了OK对 聊到这里我想插一个问题啊就是刚才我们也是我们那个呃 这边主办方另外主办方老司机这边比较关心那个问题的提了一个问题就是呃
就是如果所有事情我们都看中业务价值和技术价值的时候就是一些不确定性和探索性的事情要怎么去看待就我们刚刚聊的那个问题就是怎么去看可能它的那个成果就是这个点探索性的东西其实是可以做一些衡量的因为你像我们可以看一下平时产品体的需求它也有很多是探索性的东西
当你不确定一个收益的时候我觉得是可以去探索但是你要把探索的逻辑讲清楚你为什么要探索这个事儿你探索这个事儿之后我觉得当然我觉得探索这个算你应该完全没有一点点的收益方向对吧你可以给大概的范围例如我做成大概是什么样子的我觉得大概的预期也可以至少可以给出来
对然后以及他你要为什么探索这个方向他到底给我们团队的基础上也好业务上也好到底能够带来哪些争议这些东西我觉得还是要想清楚我觉得如果你也不清楚探索这个东西例如到底能给我们带来什么收益就盲目的去探索的话那大概率是不成功的我觉得货东还是要有一点点的一个收益预期对ok 我明白就是说其实就就算是探索新的东西嘛比如说
这种东西的话本身你还是要去讲这个所谓的业务价值和纪录价值的对而且其实我们其实往往能看到像技术员去做一些我来探索隐藉一些新技术等到像前几年横火的像超平台技术RN也好或者Flatte也好确实有团队把它们用的很好也确实产生很大的收益但是确实也不是适合每一个团队因为我经常看到某个团队可能引了RN或者引了Flatte他说可以说
相本增效因为我开发一遍就可以双端都用但是实际上我看到的很多现象是说我一个团队可能支持某个最简单最简单的页面用了阿恩或者佛拉达去开发可能只有一两个页面然后我我弄了那么大的工程搞了那么多人去引进这个技术然后还让大家去额外去多一个基础站等等但是实际上开发我们之后开发只用了一两个页面
这其实在我看来可能就是你可能探索实判最后你还要考虑把它去掉经常会有这样的事情我明白所以我觉得刚刚这个问题其实提的也挺好我觉得泽雷回答的也挺好其实说实话我觉得泽雷是相对来说比较成熟的管理者而且我觉得你应该是属于对上面和对下面都很负责的管理者
確實是的因為你再回到這個問題的時候明顯感覺到首先你肯定還是有就這種燙現東西還是比較open的這能感覺出來但同時你又比如說從上往下的角度來說的話你會給大家提出一些比較基本而且是從比較科學的角度會提出一些建議和要求這個其實還蠻重要的這個問題我覺得我們就先繼續往下走
有一个是你对责任很想聊这个问题啊这个估计我就把它交给你吧你可以来好好地聊一点对因为我觉得这个问题可能很多人也比较关心就是所谓的行业内选的一个现象嗯这个问题的时候我可以先讲一些跟这个本身这个的话题没有什么关系的事就我每天像因为我们现在
擺动彭华的办公区去办公这个办公区他车位是比较少的我每天大概9点40多以后可能公司的车位就没有了如果公司的车位没有了以后呢你就是只能停到一个比较远的地方对吧然后但是我今晚每天大概也就是9点40到9点50左右能到公司然后经常我上班路上也看到正常回去到一个公司同事的车因为他那个车很鲜艳我经常能看到他
然后每次我看到他的时候我都一脚大拥门因为我看最后有个车位被他炸了然后我觉得把车开得比较远的地方去停这个事其实跟这本事没什么相关但其实我想表达是说当一个地方是有资源的并且有人认为这个资源值得去争取的话那么就会有卷的现象
那么然后换种说法来讲我觉得整个互联网他有自己的奖场机制我们互联网有今生有迹效有年底奖金等等然后也有直级上的等等很多的奖场机制我觉得这个奖场机制一直在的话他卷的问题就一直都不会消失总有人会想我多干点那么我的年龙奖多拿一点我多干点我可以升一级我可以股票多发一点对吧总有人会想这个问题
所以說這個捲的問題我是覺得不會消失的而且換個角度來講那麼假如說互聯網有一天變得跟傳統行業一樣的薪資對吧這些獎狀機制都沒了你幹一年你幹得出色或者幹得不出色年底都是拿那些錢固定的那麼這時候可能確實就沒有人捲了但是這樣的話整個行業這個薪資待遇下來的時候我覺得是否又是大家願意看到的然後我們再看一個換成角度來講
我们都知道我们都知道一线城市是比老家三四线二三线城市要更辛苦一些但是大家还是愿意来一些城市我们明智更辛苦还是要来对吧这个问题大家可以去想想我们为什么还是要来对那说明还是因为挣更多钱这个事更值得我们去花点辛苦对其实这个问题我自己也想聊一聊就这个卷的问题啊
其实我觉得所有的这种卷其实我理解就是在今年我们或者在最近我们其实出现了这样的一些大比较负面的一个状态对不对大家可能会比较负面的观众到这个内卷的现象但其实我觉得有问题并不是在于内卷本身我觉得有问题点不在于卷本身而是因为我们可能就整个行业整个业务的发展对吧其实真的问题在于我们整个业务发展现在可能整个大的盘子
它的发展速度没有那么快对吧 我记得我们以前经常会讲就是如果一个公司在业务发展飞速的时候任何问题都不是问题我不知道泽磊你是怎么看这个问题啊就是我觉得真的只要公司业务再快速发展其实任何问题都不是问题嘛是这样的就是我觉得可以看前几年我们互联网就是风生水起的火就是各个公司发展都很快
突然就变得实质很高的时候那么这时候所有的细节问题都不是问题因为没有人纠正你的一些细节问题去追说你家里加班也好或者说说甚至是你来回来公司可能也还很好只要业务一直在高速成长那么大家都开心对吧确实是这两年整个互联网的速度放下来了然后之前像很多公司飞速发展也进入了一个平稳期的时候
那么就像移动你刚才说的一个状态其实这也导致目前可能会变得更卷一些然后其实跟很多人聊其实很多人也是说他其实也必须反对说卷或者加拔本事他其实反对是一个无效卷嗯我明白对无效卷这个这个是这样的但是其实我说实话就是我觉得这个像一直存在是偶尔是存在的就是其实我觉得在两年前或者三年前甚至四年前那个时候互联网很好的时候大家也在有很多无效的卷
这百分之百是存在的只是我觉得那个时候因为整个盘子增大了速度很快所以大家其实根本没有看到这些小的问题或者说没有看到这个主要的问题然后现在突然行业慢下来了然后大家关注到这个问题了其实我觉得是个好事情就从某些程度上来讲说明大家就是以前大家快速上这大期根本看不到自己的问题当然东西一切慢下来之后大家再回过头来反思一下发现是不是可能对吧
我以前那些所谓无异的卷我是不是应该反思一下然后另外还有一点是不是我可以再看看别的赛道就是让大家其实真的可能我觉得前面几年其实前面几年可能对大家来说反正是最危险对吧大家这个资本的狂欢其实技术人可能也在里面狂欢其实我有时候也在想说那么当现在互联网
大家都过了快速发展期的时候变得平稳的时候那么说说再过几年整个互联网可以像跟国外一样像美国的硅谷一样可能办公室来讲其实是都偏成熟了嘛那么这时候成选可能就没有什么35岁的荒涨了我就可以洗澡嘛洗澡54岁是有可能的其实刚讲的我们做移动端这个事情经常会说移动端没有人做了嘛经常我们家会讲这个点说没有人要或者没有人做了但其实我是觉得
如果大家比方如果这几年可能还有我前面几年其实有那些新人就是当然这个这个是仅代表个人观点啊我就是前面几年可能有一些那个应揭声问我要不要做移动当然我可能会选择说嗯这这件事不太不太适合做但我觉得到到最近这些阶段其实我觉得反而可以反向操作一下只是我的一点点想法
前两年培训结构不都不都在培训什么人工智能大数据什么的吗老师这两年其实你看移动端招人是很困难的对的对因为因为讲到这个移动端其实说吧你会发现新业学其实很少真的上来有很多项目经验的其实不多而且前段时间是谁是戴老师吧讲了一下说移动端后续的一个一个发展方向其实移动端大家如果不把自己局限在这个手机上面其实还是很因为
移動端嘛就是不單是中端我們現在可能不講移動端可能講中端嘛就中端技術吧如果你把這個視角放到中端技術的話其實沒有那麼小是的因為很多時候我們講移動端的時候大家可能把目光過分的聚焦在UI這個層面上了對吧對我們光在這兒對你把自己可能限制在所謂的可口可口的框架然後可能現在安卓那套對吧框架對
你如果现在那些框架里面的可能确实是你很难有更多的发挥但如果你把就像我们把世界网底层再放一下看到系统层然后你会发现其实我们现在很多的比如说IoT啊对吧IoT的设备啊这些东西包括我们现在所所谓的比较火的一些什么物联网什么之类的其实它都是中砖嘛对而且我觉得你如果只居家在系统系统的空架这一层的话
那么实际上你平时也只能完成一些业务开发你很难有一些记录上的想法对吧尤其我们谈我们讲记录项目你可能要谈记录收益等等但是因为你一直只举现在这的话那么其实你很难说自己去想一个什么样的记录项目啊这个记录项目能到底给我们业务带来什么样的收益等等你可能很难想明白这个事对吧嗯明白明白行啊那我觉得这个这个话题我觉得我们聊的也挺多的其实进入今天最后一个话题吧就接下来就是你看
比如说你对你团队还要个人大家是一个什么的规划呢团队来讲的话我们因为我们前面讲到我们团队其实是有一些记录在的我们也在做一些重复的工作那么其实接下来一段时间我们团队整个团队还是会围绕着一个共同架构和性能两个方面共同架构就像我们前面说的共同架构我们主要还是面对一个跟对一个人效的问题对吧然后性能方面的话因为我们
看到我们有很多数据也确实能够证明向与多体验提升包括等等确实会能够带动一些用上是比较增长所以说在性能上我们也会再做一个持续上的一个呃去做一个优化然后其实我个人来讲的话呃像我刚才讲排版的话其实我目前呃像我们同队来一炮排完我们其实也还没有做完我个人其实对这一块是比较有兴趣的只不过目前团队业务续修团可能暂时不需要接入一炮这种资源而已对但是我个人对这块其实挺有兴趣的
因为它设计到的排版规则包括我记得是应该是一二年还是一三年已经发布了一泡泡三这种排版规则但是其实业界做一泡泡三的应该还是很少对其实我也想去做一些方面的东西可是我个人方面一些就算有外的一些小规划好的好的行那我觉得我们今天的整个访谈的部分就到这里吧OK然后非常感谢则磊给出的一些精彩的观点